vous n'imaginez pas faire un bâtiment
sans modèle vous ne pourriez pas imaginé
de mettre 100 ouvriers avec des paquets
de briques de ciment et de dire allez-y
construisez le bâtiment sans modèle une
parabole qui pourrait s'appliquer aux
modèles informatiques
car bien des logiciels ne fournissent
pas de modèle concret aux développeurs
qui travaillent en aveugle fort de ce
constat l'entreprise softeam précurseur
en la matière a donc créé le logiciel
modelio il s'adapte aux interlocuteurs
et au coeur de métier et permet de
donner une vue différente à chacun s'ils
ont un modèle trop technique face à un
utilisateur ou un manager
le dialogue ne va pas se produire et
donc partant de ces modèles on a semblé
vue de chacun et ça nous permet de
descendre jusqu'à la réalisation du
développeur
ces modèles permettent aussi de générer
des codes automatiquement d'éviter ainsi
les erreurs humaines et de faire des
contrôles de cohérence des fonctions qui
apporte un vrai gain en termes de
productivité et d'emploi
la création de ce logiciel dont philippe
des frais est l'inventeur a engendré le
succès de softeam de par le monde
l'entreprise guyancourt toise emploie
aujourd'hui 700 personnes